let me get to Trey for a sec so um
you're the only one who's married yes
okay so we're also kind of speaking in
hypotheticals uh you not only uh
attained your woman she you're she's
retained you the whole thing right what
were the qualities that I tried three
qualities that attracted you to her what
were the how did that Dynamic work well
loyalty I mean the in terms of
characteristics I'm gonna just do three
and I'm gonna do them I'm gonna try to
be brief about it but loyalty if I can't
assure a paternity then that's a huge
that's a No-No for me and I think it
shows a lot of character in women too
and you can be loyal to one man and if
that's not there it doesn't matter how
attractive you are that's you know it's
out of the window second one is her
submissiveness uh or her I won't even
say submissive I'll just say femininity
uh when we were kids she was already
making my plate that was the first time
I've ever had a woman make my plate and
from that point on I was like I'm gonna
marry this woman what do you mean when
you were kids you're making your plate
15 16 years old if I go over to her
house or if she was at my house she
would stand up and maybe a girl when you
were a teenager yeah you've been with
her for this whole time yes wow yeah you
guys lost your virginity to each other
yes only woman you've ever been with yes
wow she's only got what
class
do you guys like the video okay do you
know something's happening when a porn
star is like hey well on you buddy yeah
meaning like that you can find a woman
with a good character that's the goal
for many men like if I find a attractive
loyal feminine woman and those are my
three by the way
in this order loyal uh feminine and
attractive okay the femininity comes
from the fact that the social status
thing too as well I think femininity is
also a reciprocation of value if you see
me waking up 6 a.m every day while you
get to sleep in the 2PM because you're a
housewife can you make my plate you know
I mean like a lot of women will see that
as the least you can do is make me a
sandwich it's dingo and I know people
are going to be offended by that they're
going to clip that whatever it may be
but that is what it is I've never seen a
group of men sit down and have my drink
filled up by my wife to say
uh make fun of her right so like
women will say women will say you
shouldn't do that because it makes you
look weak I've never seen men ostracize
of women from being too feminine the
only people I see making fun of women
for taking care of their families are
like 18 year olds in Call of Duty
lobbies feminists and other women
exactly and women are
men like yes and they'll be they'll be
the ones to get inside of a woman's head
and have a second guessing right exactly
right but there's a fulfillment when you
take care of your man because it's like
as a woman I feel like you know like you
really don't want to out make your man
so it's like how do I make up for that
and I'll do it in other years like
making his playing getting him drinks
and like you know cleaning other stuff
like you want to kind of be the villain
where they lack so it's like that's what
kind of where but women are mean they
get really nasty yeah those are the only
people that make fun of other women that
are submissive I had a guy one of my
friends he came over to my house in Fort
Worth not too long ago he owns a
construction company at 25 years old the
dude is killing it he had a girlfriend
that was living with him that refused to
make him a plate she refused to cook for
him or anything he was like I'm not even
asking for much I just want you to put
noodles in a pot with water that's all I
require from you the man owns a
construction company and he couldn't
even get that so that just goes to show
how far we are in terms of women just
being so against showing Reciprocity for
the things that their men do for them so
you can't expect a man to die for you
but you're not willing so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]